Imagine a future where one day...
...machine learning will give you the power to track your sleep, imagine...
Excuse me, ma'am?
Yes, can I help you?
Yeah, this already does that.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Well, now you do.
Okay let's try this again, it's alright, I'll start again.
Imagine one day a tiny device with an optical sensor...
...will send you an alert if your heart rate is too low.
Yes, what?
It already does that.
Okay, well how about will send you an alert if your heart rate is too high.
It already does that!
Alright, let's try something new.
Will send you an alert if you're some place that's too loud.
I just received one of those alerts.
Really, well you should probably find a quieter place sir!
You should probably mind your own business.
Okay, imagine, one day in the future...
Hold on.
No, no, no let me finish!
One second.
You'll be able to take an E-C-G...
It already does that, it already does that.
I heard that.
Good, what about continuously track your elevation, does it do that?
Does that.
Right, got it.
Thank you.
Does that.
Yeah, heard it the first time.
Encourages you to stay fit?
Does that.
Okay, I get it, you're fit, umm I don't know.
Will it automatically call 9-1-1 if a bear chases you off a cliff...
...and you take a hard fall, huh?
Yeah, already does that.
Seriously?
Yeah, seriously.
You've got to be kidding me.